Hey friends, this is Emily.
I've got some exciting news.
It's so exciting, I just can't stop smiling.
You may be asking yourself, "What is this exciting news Emily, what is it?"
"Tell me right now!" And I will.
I'm gonna be starting a brand new video series called, "So, you wanna go to America?"
In my new series of videos, I'm gonna be telling you about...
...well, for those of you who don't know much about America,...
...all about America because it's a wonderful, wonderful place with amazing people.
Laughs and giggles, and just so much fun.
And all these videos are gonna be available, subtitled in Japanese and English,...
...on a brand new website called "EnglishCentral.com".
And it has a software where you can read back English into the software...
...and it will compare your pronunciation and rank it to the pronunciation of a native English speaker such as myself.
My English is so native, it's amazing.
Practice speaking English back to the video.
To learn how to say what I say.
Do what I do.
Be cool like I am.
For real, for shizzle, yo, yo what's up, represent.
So, anyway, I'm gonna be telling you tips...
...for what you should and should not do when going to America.
Like, how to go to a bar.
How to order a coffee.
How to not get into a fight.
How to not get killed.
How to not get pickpocketed.
Just that sort of thing.
Like, did you know that you shouldn't get in a bar fight?
You might have not, now you do.
Thanks to me and my hot super special awesome tips.
So go and check out EnglishCentral.com when you have a minute.
Heck, I'm sure you have lots of minutes... that's why you're online right now.
Go outside.
Take a walk.
Go fishing.
I'll see you at EnglishCentral.